welcome back it just wouldn't be a new
year without making some resolutions
let's go around the table find out what
we have in store for ourselves judge
what did you get you know here's the
problem when you make the same
resolution every year yeah you know that
there's a problem okay and so this year
my resolution guess less chocolate you
got it Tyler
all right Tyrus is like in my in the
room right next to me it's sugar it's a
terrible thing it messes up your head
your body everything get rid of sugar
now if I could only convince myself of
that all right that's a but we will see
if we can help you but there's tires she
literally has her own segment on the
show candy with the judge what are you
talking about a bunch of enablers
how about sugar-free with judge be
supportive sugar free candy that's a
boring yeah that's about carcinogens and
it turns into relaxing all right fine
laxative I thought only I screamed it
yeah
okay my resolution is to be nicer to
Jessica again was that it last year yeah
it didn't work I mean I saw maternity
leave and I saw it and I thought oh
that's nice and then I got back and I
was like he forgot something about you
I just want to interrupt you I have to
work on interrupting and that's
something I really will try hard Jesse I
got over it I used to interrupt you all
the time remember
I still I don't it's a holiday so I
don't want to break it to you like this
but you still interrupt me yeah
Jessica you're next
um I need to read more like books
no but books and I'm always you and Dana
are always saying like oh you're reading
this reading that and I don't make
enough time to sit there and actually
have a baby guys it's a yeah okay all
right let me try I'm gonna give you
something I would like that I'll give
you more TV okay steel okay anything
else next oh we're still going I use my
phone less around family and then lead
with kindness and patience I need to not
jump yes I need to do that yeah we
really should I think that Jesse is a
good role model and you are too tireless
of not using your phone a lot in front
of your families
is that true yeah yeah
it's impressive he's good about it okay
mine are this I really resolve to get my
Tech life in order there was a time like
right around the election everything's
super busy everything's on the phone and
I had a problem with my phone and I just
decided I wanted to go back to pen and
paper and Pen because I was so
frustrated yeah because there's too many
apps I feel like I'm paying for like 10
subscriptions to show time I don't I
want to get my whole Tech thing in order
so I might even hire somebody to come
and help me if you're a teenager and you
want to come over to the apartment and
help me get this figured out I would
appreciate it because maybe you could
say that yeah
that's true the second my second
resolution and we've been meaning to do
this we are going to do it this year I
want to take ballroom dancing lessons
with Peter oh
yeah what do I want to do does Peter
want to take ballroom dancing with you
yeah well hopefully I mean I think so
he's an English gentleman I'm sure
that's yeah all right Tyrus also a guy
hi um my resolution is to eat more
apples uh and not use pronouns unless
it's in a sentence I'm not going to do
the pronoun thing okay okay and I'm
gonna do more stand-up live shows
you absolutely all can come to him so
I'm going to be there for free more
shows can I go for free for judge yes
you because I'll make more money on you
and the candy in the mark section
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else